i really want to go in one of those like
uh i know they had it in like cashews
castle yeah they had the the challenge
where you had to like sit in like the
japanese tatami room yeah on one of
those earthquake uh simulation things oh
yeah and they have to like try and sit
on the platform without falling over
while it's like magnitude 9.
i really want to go i've i've been on
one of those oh dude yeah that sounds
fun yeah i did a video at like the like
emergency center oh yeah yeah in japan
and like
where you get to experience like a house
fire and like an earthquake and stuff
like that and they have one of those
things and i tried it on magnitude nine
which is the same as the 2011 earthquake
right dude it's crazy like right what
does it feel like it just it just feels
like four guys are just surrounding you
just doing this
like
like you can't even like i was sitting
down like legs crossed i was sitting
down and like after the first shake like
i was
like holy [ __ ] like you cannot even
like lie down straight like it's so
[ __ ] intense
and so it really like went to sleep like
you know when you hear magnitude 9 right
you're like oh [ __ ] that seems really
big but i think like actually
experiencing magnitude 9 is
isn't it exponential yeah i think they
just like whoever whoever designed the
richter scale really
really like [ __ ] up by making it a
logarith uh logarithmic scale because
it's not like it's not uh linear right
so it's like it's logarithmic no do you
mean exponential
i
it's the inverse of exponential is it so
logarithmic means that it goes like this
and then exponential means it goes like
okay i might be wrong
i just wanted to say logarithmic one of
them
the gains that you see are initial and
then it starts flattening out whereas
exponential is the opposite
oh it is logarithmic thank you okay but
you were trying to explain the
exponential i'm smart
you said the right word but you were
saying the wrong thing
what i'm saying is we're professionals
exponential is kind of and also
logarithmic kind of it's the inverse of
a logarithm
yeah i don't know about that i don't
know i don't know because like it's the
opposite
i don't know i mean
by the way it's like okay it's not
linear it's not linear it's it's in a
scale yes yes actually logarithmic
functions are the inverses of
exponential functions
so how is this oh wait so richter scale
is logarithmic richter scale is
logarithmic so that means that it would
the the after like four or five the
difference isn't much
that
hence the word exponential it goes
exponentially higher this kind of just
what this kind of just proves my points
the original point i was trying to make
was that they you they put it in a scale
that is not comprehendable by the normal
human person which we are which we are
literally proving
right now
you know like but like you hear about
you hear like an eight or nine on the
richter scale and you're just like oh
that's just one up from a seven and i've
seen people survive sevens
your mind can't comprehend the the
effects like the the tangible effects of
just how much larger that is you know
yeah yeah and that's that's why that's
why i think they [ __ ] up because if
you hear like oh it was
on a scale of like a thousand on like
this earthquake scale you're like that's
that's a big number compared to compared
to 100 which is which is what which is
what we're technically talking about
when we're talking going up from
magnitude seven to a magnitude eight yes
yes and i think
like i i don't know why we went with a
logarithmic logarithmic scale for like
disasters when the normal person can't
comprehend that amount of difference
with just one number you know sure yeah
i mean can't even comprehend what
logarithmic and exponential are so how
is he going to compensate any one of us
can i can i know what it is
yeah i know i'm right
but the rigor scale is a logarithmic
logarithmic scale that's logarithmic
yeah so that means that there wouldn't
be much difference between eight and
nine
but there is
well
the scale says that there isn't jay oh
for the sake
is that right there's not much of a
difference between eight and nine
i don't know
i can't wait for the comments to just
tear this conversation apart hi
mathematician here
hi mathematician i literally have a
aneurysm i invented the richter scale
i'm having an end user technically it's
supposed to
indicate an intensity ten times yeah the
previous yeah that's that's what it's
also described as a logarithmic scale so
i don't know yeah that's what i
logarithmic [ __ ] line i know i know
what a logarithmic line is but it
doesn't make sense because i've learned
that the richter scale is the higher the
number the bigger the difference in
scale
i thought it was like 10 times the
previous number yeah right no because
what i mean i guess it could be but also
because it goes like this right right so
let's say this was like eight if it was
eight like at the peak or something yeah
it's not going to get much better at
nine i sorry increase more sorry then
what oh my god i don't know so that's
i
i i am i am i am confusion
also i love the rhythmic scale also
depends on the function you put into it
yeah that's what i thought because the
logarithmic logarithmic scale doesn't
necessarily have to look like that it's
just
as a scale that's not linear yes it's
not just a non-linear scale it's uh
yeah so that's that is a logarithmic
logarithmic and that is also what i
understand to be exponential as well
that's what i thought it's an
exponential logarithmic scale that's
what i thought at least it's an
exponential logarithmic yeah yeah oh
because it keeps going up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so
so either way either way my original
point wasn't
wasn't the fact that exponentials are
the same as logarithmic that wasn't what
i was trying to explain i was trying to
explain that
i'm right
either way i was trying to say that this
[ __ ] is too confusing for the normal
person to comprehend which maybe we
aren't more we aren't the normal person
maybe we're just dumber than a normal
speaker yourself maybe we'll just dump
bottom line you bottom line you could
say that the earthquake yesterday was
magnitude seven yeah but if you've never
been in an earthquake of that magnitude
you're not going to [ __ ] know what
that feels like right yeah like you guys
have never been in a magnitude seven
yesterday was a magnitude like four max
in tokyo yeah and like that's fun zone
for me yeah
i think six six sounds scary six i
wonder what how big the one in la was
that we experienced i want to say that
was probably around the same like maybe
like a magnitude four yeah
it wasn't it was it felt around well it
depends like where we were it wasn't it
didn't feel that bad yeah but i can't
imagine what it is like even if it goes
like if if it's like ten times more
powerful than that i mean i've been in a
six as the is the biggest
america is the most volcanoes in the
world does it
not active but total volcanoes oh really
no whereabouts just a whole lot
the whole thing well i think hawaii is a
lot yeah of active ones right but and in
general america's a lot more than japan
yeah more volcanoes than japan wow i
thought japan had the most no maybe
japan is the most active ones no that's
indonesia
yeah i think that is indonesia japan
can't be number one america also has
like a massive landmass yeah so i'm not
like surprised about it because the most
volcanoes that like aren't active like
they're just like don't do anything yeah
yeah then they have like yellowstone
which is like a ticking time bomb for
extinction you know
i mean i mean it kind of is right if
yellowstone ever explodes then uh
humanity [ __ ] uh yeah well same with
malfuji right yeah i think as well
there's
if any volcanoes erupt in the antarctic
i think there's i think there's some
volcanoes underneath the ice yeah yeah
yeah and if they explode then
it's just gone yeah well but the world's
gone
that water's got to go somewhere
is really good at keeping that [ __ ] in